how's it going bros my name is power I
have some exciting news today you
brothers know that I love [ __ ] about
with Photoshop I've been doing so many
videos of it and it's been an amazing
funnily time that is a sentence yes but
now it's time for you bros to
participate I posted a bunch of pictures
on myself
not that kind of pictures you can
download them in the description and I
want you bros to take these pictures and
make whatever you want with them you can
make something weird something funny
something scary something sexy
they're already sexy all the info will
be down in the description I will take
the ones that I enjoy the most and I
will show them in the next video of
Photoshop I think it'll be a lot of fun
and I'm super excited for this so do
check them out and if you just want some
nice pics of me there or down there
alright that's all you need to know now
good for this video to not be too boring
I'm gonna now do a dancing montage for
30 seconds
stay awesome